dans les hôpitaux ce geste est en
principe un automatisme se désinfecter
les mains chaque fois que l'on entre et
que l'on sort d'une chambre
nous on atteint les 70% ne gênait main
et on a une augmentation de près de 20 %
venant le centre intégré de santé et de
services sociaux de laval atteint la
cible provincial de 70% de conformité
aux pratiques d'hygiène des mains des 21
établissements qui nous ont fourni leurs
données le sis de laval est le seul qui
l'a déjà atteintes d'autres s'en
approche comme le 6 de chaudière
appalaches et celui de l'outaouais
treize établissements ont des notes
allant de 50 à 65 % de conformité on
retrouve en queue de peloton le chum de
montréal à 44% de conformité le ciss du
bas saint laurent à 34% et le sus de la
capitale nationale avec seulement 31 %
très mauvais résultat pour
l'établissement universitaire qui promet
de former les nouveaux employés
on va fa signer un engagement écrit à
tous les employés qu'ils vont procéder à
l'hygiène des mains
difficile d'expliquer cette négligence
dans le lavage des mains surtout que
dans la moitié des établissements pour
lesquels nous avons obtenu des données
ce sont les médecins et qui dérogent le
plus à la consigne
je peux malheureusement pas l'expliquer
j'aimerais vraiment pouvoir l'expliquer
parce que je me précipiterai vers une
solution passer des bleus à lutter on
parle ici de la mesure le plus
élémentaire
dans les soins santé déplorable surtout
quand on compare le québec avec la
province voisine
en ontario le taux de conformité à
l'hygiène des mains dans les hôpitaux
atteint 90% l'atteinte des objectifs
québécois pourrait prendre du temps pour
instaurer un changement de culture dans
les hôpitaux
c'est évidemment une question d'honneur
tous les établissements devront
améliorer leur performance d'ici 2020
québec veut que la conformité aux
pratiques d'hygiène atteignent 80 % ici
david gentil la radio canada montréal